Edward Snowden thank you so much for
joining us we're talking from the
Liberty Forum of the Free State Project
which in 2003 created a project where
they said we're going to get 20,000
people to agree to move to New Hampshire
and make the state a freer and more
interesting more innovative and fun
place recently passed the 20,000 mark so
the great migration has become has
started and at some point I've been
asked to welcome you to come to New
Hampshire to a free state when you have
time and I've been told that among other
things it would be a free and
independent New Hampshire they're even
getting rid of the state liquor stores
and they're not going to have
extradition with the rest of the United
States so public enjoy let's talk about
the story that's very much in the news
now the issue of Apple being requested
by a court order to unlock the cell
phone of one of the San Bernardino
shooters you recently tweeted this is
the most important tech case in a decade
silence means that Google picked a side
but it's not the public's can you
elaborate on that and is Apple really on
the public side and how does strong
encryption of personal communication
even when utilized by terrorists
strengthen freedom and liberty this is
an incredibly complex sort of topic when
you think about the whole Google Apple
thing first off Google did come forward
their CEO made some comments in a sort
of the defense of the ability of private
enterprises not to be conscripted by
government it's a sort of do software
work at their direction rather than at
the direction of their customers now it
was very tentative but hey it's a start
and when we think about sort of Apple
you know are they the big champions of
Liberty of individual rights it's not
really about that we're not looking for
the perfect heroes here right it's a
don't love the actor love the act
and what we see is that what the FBI is
asking for here right is in the wake of
the San Bernardino shootings which are
you know of course legitimate crimes
this is an act of terrorism as it's been
described and they said all right
we've got this private product out there
that was designed to protect the
security of all customers not a
particular individual customer but it's
a binary choice either all of us have
security or none of us have security and
so the FBI went well yeah yeah that's
great but we want you to strip out some
essential protections that you built
into this program so that we can attack
the program in a certain way and as a
technologist this is deeply disturbing
to me because I know that we've had
laboratory techniques since the 1990s
that allow us all guys laboratory
techniques since the 1990s that allow
the FBI and other organizations that
have incredible resources to
unilaterally mount Hardware attacks and
security devices to re-engineer their
software without compelling private
actors private enterprises private
individuals to are contrary to their
will now prior to this their important
court precedents that have equated code
to speech it's an act of creation an act
of expression when you are programming
something which is no different than
sort of writing a paper or building a
house these are things that are guided
by your intention and if the government
can show up at any time any house any
individual and say regardless of your
intention regardless of your ideas
regardless of your plan you don't work
for you you work for us
that's a radically different thing and
whether it's Apple or Google or anybody
else somebody else who at least
challenges that assertion of authority
and allows us to litigate that both in
the courts in in the public domain this
is critical because prior to this moment
these things were being litigated in
secret in front
secret court the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court that in 33 years was
asked by the government thirty-three
thousand nine hundred times to authorize
a surveillance or reinterpretations of
statutory law that are more favorable to
the government that we never knew about
because all of these decisions are
classified and in those thirty three
thousand nine hundred times and 33 years
the government got to know from this
court only eleven times and thirty three
that's why it lowers here that's why
things can I ask a follow-up question
and part of this is legal but part of it
is also kind of technological I mean is
any communication really secure anymore
you know David Brin 20 years ago talked
about the transparent society about your
privacy is done get over it
and if no communication is really secure
anymore is it a problem or or is there a
way to actually hold the government
accountable or to restrain it or
corporations for that matter I mean what
you know is this beyond a question of
government acting and corporate acting
and individual acting because certainly
Brin was writing long before Facebook
and social media where people are giving
away you know just oodles of information
again and again so you know is is any
communication private anymore and if it
isn't then what next the idea here is
there there are different kinds of
surveillance right there's mass
surveillance which is typically done of
communications in transit right as they
cross the internet over lines that you
don't own but you don't have a choice
not to use because of the nature of the
modern communications grid you can't say
I want my communications to only route
for this network once they leave your
home once they leave you or a handset
for yourself on or whatever device
you're using it's out of your control
and it gets routed invisibly across
borders across systems across
enterprises the danger of this is that
any one of these actors whether they're
corporate actors whether the
government's and we know for a fact that
governments particularly are using this
capability as they transit
if they're transient electronically
naked that is unencrypted anybody can
read these they can capture these they
can store these they can do whatever
they want with them and there's no
indication that it happened so this is
the property of course that spies like
whether they're their corporate or state
it's that nobody they tell people don't
even know that LARPing must mean that
they're right does this does this mean
that there's nothing that works no there
are ways to shelter the content of the
communication which is basically if you
think about what's in the email what's
in the order register with amazon.com or
you know that the call that you made on
a voice over IP system or the text
message that you send through a certain
app they can no longer read that all
they can see what you're doing is those
communications that were electronically
naked have now been closed
they've been armored in a kind of thing
that means you know they can't just kind
of look under your skirt and see what's
happening there all they can see is that
now there's a covered wagon sort of
moving down the trail that cover allows
you to have some measure of privacy but
there's still a danger here which is
they can monitor the movements of the
wagons and this is what the government
refers to as metadata how non-experts
should think about is me data it's data
about their perfect records of private
lives in the activities since they can't
see what you're saying they can see who
you're saying it to when you are saying
it with what frequency intelligence
agencies use this information to derive
what we call the pattern of the life of
individuals and it's very much the same
as what a private eye would develop and
create a store if they were following
you around all day they can't sit beside
you at every cafe you're going to
because you'll notice hey that's the
same guy that was there all the time or
why is this guy leaning over and light
able to hear my conversation but they'll
be near enough to see who you're meeting
with when you got there what the license
plate of your car was when you left
where you traveled where you've slept at
night now this stuff is being done on a
mask
indiscriminate scale to all of us even
today it's sort of after these reforms
the government stopped holding these
repositories of data for a particular
phone collection program who everybody
in the country calls but they said the
phone companies can still hold this
information and we'll just ask them for
it but for the Internet they haven't
made any changes to those programs as a
result now when we talk about that the
direct factual challenge is there there
are two points one is armoring the in
transit communications this is a
principle called
end-to-end encryption now the founding
fathers in the United States used
encryption to protect their
communications Benjamin Franklin created
a number of ciphering systems himself
because he recognized that when great
power has intensely detailed private
information about the political
activities of groups that are acting in
manners that they would find
inconvenient or burdens it's going to be
a very short revolution and we would
have lost so they've sort of a certain
means of defense that is what is
happening today for the Internet is a
standard it's not target against the
United States government it's targeted
against all actors who seek to subvert
the intention of the users we're trying
to protect everyone everywhere our cross
borders we're not just fighting the NSA
right this is about China Russia North
Korea Iran whoever you're afraid of we
can protect everyone from all of them by
working together now there is still that
further measure of metadata Saur me data
again the private activity records where
how do we conceal the fact that a
communication occurred as opposed to the
details that occurred within it and
that's still an area of active research
there are programs that are developed
that do help with this but this is still
actively topical research you're you're
not against the government
actually acting in to ensure to help the
safety of citizens can you talk a little
bit about what what would what would a
government surveillance program
that is legal and effective look like
for you well the first point here is to
recognize that the nature of open
societies free societies right nations
and Liberty is that life does entail
some measure of risk you're only going
to be perfectly protected if you sort of
bury yourself onto the ground you're
living in prison and then you'll still
be at risk from the inmates or sort of a
walking the asylum with you life
involves risk it involves chokes
involves contest that's where it derives
its value from that's where we progress
from we are tested every day by our
environment now that doesn't mean we we
sort of open the vest and assume that we
should be vulnerable to any actor
anywhere who wants to do us harm now of
course we should take reasonable
measures and we should work to create
capabilities and measures that allow us
to identify wrongdoers and punish the
wicked as things have always worked
throughout sort of human history now the
method of law enforcement that we know
works has been the model for thousands
of years that has done so and that is
that we use what's called a
particularity requirement which is
really what the Fourth Amendment is
about in legal terms the idea is we
don't have a general warrant where the
court says that anybody you think might
be related to some class of activity
whether that's political radicalism or
anything like that now you just go well
we think they're like that so we're
going to look at them instead you need
some probable cause that you can
demonstrate to a court right this isn't
just a gut feeling you have to be able
to lay out the evidence that this
individual is engaged in some kind of
wrongdoing if they are a criminal and it
meets a threshold that allows the court
and the public sort of by a proxy to go
the interest in sort of limiting these
rights for this particular period of
investigation for the public outweighs
that of the natural right that we all
enjoy to be left alone without
reasonable cost
now this is what has changed in the wake
of 9/11 and particularly what 2013
revealed if the government is targeting
a particular device of an individual or
they're trying to tap a phone an office
that they know is involved in mob
activity there's nothing wrong with that
that's what we've always done we've done
this for hundreds of years we have to
have those methods of investigations but
at the same time pre criminal
investigation that is watching all of us
all of the time because we might some
day become interesting right they want
to go back in time and look at all the
records that they correct collected in
advance the government calls this bulk
collection every one ounce cause of mass
surveillance and say well you know
you've come to our attention today but
we know what you did on you know June
5th 1992 and we don't like that that's a
problem because it radically reorders
the balance of power in society it is
preemptively restricting our rights
without any cause to do so to create a
sort of surveillance time machine that
allows them to go back and say no matter
what you've done we know what that was
we can analyze you we can assess you and
why this matters is it's no longer
justice it's only order and these are
very different things I'm you know six
years ago this month in 2010 and an ARS
technica forum under your unfortunate
pseudonym the true hoo-ha you asked did
we did we get to where we are today via
a slippery slope that was entirely
within our control to stop and I'm
quoting you or was it a relatively
instantaneous sea change that sneaked in
undetected because of pervasive
government secrecy you know with what
you were just talking about how would
you answer that question now was it you
know are we are we frogs in a pot of
water that's getting warmer and warmer
or was there a switch that was turned on
and that's that's how this happened so
first off let me caveat as a privacy at
kid I've never publicly owned these
posts and this is not to say you know
all these aren't beaten or anything like
that the individual in question who
authored these posts seems to have a
suspiciously large amount of correlating
events in their life that match mine
here the point here is that when
individuals right understands right
there's a reason for that so individuals
can be judged on the basis of their
ideas their engagement in a particular
conversation rather than their
personalities and this has been a
concept that has moved for public
discussion I mean the public comes you
know not necessarily on and then
certainly in American history the
constant the Federalist Papers I mean we
are a country that was founded on
anonymous speech in many ways so your
participant or you or whoever was was
participating in a grand tradition for
for the sake of argument let's presume
that individual was me ah the idea here
is could we have arrested this slot and
at the time contemporaneous to that I
think it was circa 2009 2010 I was still
working for the CI had just moved to the
NSA I believe and I didn't have the same
kind of comprehensive insights as to how
the system had arisen and of course if I
would have been in this position writing
as this individual the idea would be
well we should have seen this coming
right
it would have been incremental there
would have been some public indications
but when you look at the public record
of how sort of the institutions of mass
surveillance occurred in the United
States they occurred under a veil of
secrecy and when officials were
challenged by them even under oath even
on camera they lied about them and this
is something important if we sort of
rewind to that post 2013 moment there
were stories published in 2006 ruling
warrantless wiretapping more James
Bamford in 2012 and when you look at
sort of statements in front of Congress
they looked a lot like this between
representative Hank Johnson and former
director of the earth sorry former
director Keith Alexander the NSA does
the NSA routinely intercept American
citizens emails now does the NSA
intercept American's cell phone
conversations now Google searches now
text messages now amazon.com orders no
bank records no does the NSA collect any
type of data at all on millions or
hundreds of millions of Americans no sir
it does not
not wittingly the cases where they could
inadvertently perhaps collect but not
not wittingly so this is sort of a
challenge
can we stop policies can we arrest them
can we have a voice in them can we have
a vote on them if they're intentionally
and wittingly concealed from us talk
about how does the government you know
by all indications if you look at Gallup
or Pew or other surveys trust and
confidence in government to either be
effective or to do the right thing these
are at at or near historic lows how does
government win back the trust because
again you know and I'm going to ask the
libertarian question in a second but
most of us here are libertarians not
anarchists and the anarchist is crying
in the background there but
but how does government gain back the
trust and the confidence of the American
people because we saw this in the 70s
with the Church Commission hearings and
a general hollowing out of belief in
government and you know we want a
government that is smaller than it is
perhaps but is effective and is
legitimate how does government went back
the people's trust accountability I mean
the whole idea behind the divide and and
the simple language of a private citizen
and a public official is that we know
everything about them and they know
nothing about us because they are
invested with powers and privileges that
we don't have they have the ability to
sort of direct the future of society and
as a result it is incumbent upon them to
assume a level of responsibility and
accountability to the public for the
exercise and abuse of those authorities
it simply does not exist today and
that's the problem they know more about
us than they ever have in the history of
the United States and some would argue
in any society that is a sort of existed
before at the same time the thanks to
aggressive expansions of the state
secrecy authorities and use of
classification and so on so forth and
even simple management of the press
where you know they play leaking games
they don't give comment on this that or
the other or more directly aggressive
things like we just solved with the
Director of National Intelligence who's
the most senior intelligence official in
the United States they are excusing
themselves from accountability to us at
the same time they're trying to exert
greater power over us and that I think
leads to an inevitable result over time
whether for good intentions or bad that
the public is no longer partner to
government but merely subject answer
this because this goes to that question
of accountability you've talked about
how there's really no difference between
the Democratic Party and the Republican
Party the two major parties on these
issues how does a country that offers up
you know something like three dozen
varieties of pop-tarts in every
supermarket
how are we reduced to an on choice in
the political process and not just
despair but how do we how do we change
that so that there are voices that are
saying you know what maybe surveillance
state needs to be talked about more I'm
an engineer not a politician
so my opinions being what they are I
look at systems in terms of incentives
where are the incentives and how does
human behavior emerge in response to
those incentives we've approached what
in game theory terms is called a Nash
equilibrium which is where you've got a
limited set of choices that each player
and game can make and they've identified
what is the most optimal move that they
can make within the context of that game
and so they play the same move every
time hoping that in some rounds they'll
win even if over time it means they'll
lose because they'll have the maximized
score possible for the given set of
constraints that exist now what this
means is that people go well I dislike
this side I dislike this individual I
dislike this tribe more than I dislike
the other therefore I'll pick this one
so they start voting against um and it's
important to have the principle of
understanding uh who I will vote for but
also who I won't vote for but we need to
disentangle this from parties one of the
reasons that I have an endorsed anyone
in the election is that I don't believe
there's anyone in the race that
represents my values at the currents at
a time now this isn't to say this won't
develop this won't change but it's not
about who you hate the most
right it's about who represents you and
not voting is also a powerful action but
you're revoking a mandate now this can't
work forever
it works in a tactical sense but we need
to think more broadly back in the kind
of Samuel Adams sense right that small
groups of people who are politically
passionate can sort of light brush fires
of Liberty in the minds of men
so can I ask on a technical question
then can you vote in the election I mean
where do you can you send in an absentee
ballot this would be and if you do well
you will you make your vote public it's
a secret ballot but it would be kind of
an interesting observation to see who
you voted for talking you is this is
still a topic of active research okay
yes how do you define your politics or
ideology and where did it come from do
you consider yourself a libertarian or a
classical liberal or these terms that
are meaningful to you well you know
there there's a whole field of political
theory that I don't really subscribe to
in terms of classifying people on the
basis of their beliefs because what it's
trying to do is it's trying to establish
tribes it's trying to establish common
identities and well I do think that is
valuable and important for the sense of
collective action for me it's not really
the right fit I do see sort of a clear
distinction between people who have a
larger faith in liberties and rights
than they do in states and institutions
and this would be sort of the
authoritarian libertarian axis in the
traditional sense and I do think it's
clear that if you believe in the
progressive liberal tradition which is
that people should have greater
capability to act freely to make their
own choices to invoke enjoy a better and
freer life over the progression of sort
of human evolution you're going to be
pushing away from that authoritarian
axis at all times because
authoritarianism is necessarily about
the ordering and control of society now
they can argue that that will produce a
better quality of life but it cannot be
argued that it will provide a freer life
and for me I'm on the side freedom
and you you have written in the past or
said our rights are not granted by
governments they are inherent to our
nature it's entirely the opposite for
government their privileges are
precisely equal to only to only those
which we suffer them to enjoy that's
coming out of a classical liberal
tradition of the American Fed the birth
of American Founding you're an
autodidact in many ways you you know you
don't have fancy degrees and you know I
don't see diplomas on the wall behind
you talk a little bit about the process
how did you educate yourself and how
does that play into larger roles of the
types of education that governments or
societies give people is it to liberate
them is it to kind of subjugate them and
talk about where you came from in terms
of your ideas and your self learning I
don't want to necessarily say that the
modern education system is intended to
subjugate people but we do know clearly
that it's overlaying a certain set
values upon everybody who's engaged in
that system now those values don't fit
everyone and one might say they're not
even appropriate values for a broad and
diverse sort of little a lot a
particularly one which has to go to cast
votes in a self informed critically
thinking way rather than one where you
know the majority of education is this
is the history of this part in that
party for me yes I did not graduate from
high school instead I got a GED and I
don't have the formal education now
that's held me back in a lot of ways in
in terms of just wanting to have some
kind of formal education it's difficult
to go back and get later on like
chemistry right I'm really interested in
chemistry but lacking the formal
education it's just kind of a pain to go
back and read textbooks later on at the
same time I have a very broad and
diverse educational number of different
topics and this has helped me in my
professional career because I was a much
more conversant and fluent
number of topics that ended up being
very highly valued in the national
security space that really aren't taught
in school particularly when it comes to
sort of systems security and anonymity
online in certain ways how to combat
that this illustrates a key point which
has been reflected by other thinkers
before it's it's not original to myself
which is there is a very strong
difference a bright line difference
between your schooling and your
education and we should all be careful
not to let the wall influence the other
talk about
I mean you because you were working with
people and you've talked about this who
had similar backgrounds and technical
skills but then you brought a moral
dimension to what you were seeing what
you were working for the government or
as a subcontractor did your education I
mean is it a moral education that was
lacking in the people around you or was
there something in the way that you
learned that triggered that sense of
saying you know what we all know this is
unconstitutional
or this is wrong but it was you who
decided to actually bring it to the
public's attention well I
I represented a different generation
many ways the majority sort of the the
institutional structure at the NSA and
CIA because of course I was the new
group in but I was also sort of the
first generation of children of the
internet right when you think about
where my biggest influence are in that
context my reading my writing well of
course yeah we read the history of
course yeah we read the books and the
traditions in the classics as well which
classics do you get directed to which
come to your attention that becomes part
of sort of zeitgeist debate that occurs
all around the world you have a much
larger mixing of perspectives and
because of that nationalism is blind
nationalism is less effective in many
ways because there's a very real
difference between allegiance to country
allegiance to people and allegiance to
state which is what nationalism today is
really more about the institution can
come and go but the people remain
and this this kind of context is what
differed I brought a constitution in and
put it on my desk because I had a
personal interest and I thought it was
relevant to the work and there were a
number of the people that I worked with
coworkers and colleagues particularly
when I started raising sort of the alarm
apparently about these programs and
saying something doesn't smell right
here who agreed with me who were
interested who had different
interpretations who challenged back and
forth but who cared and then there were
others who didn't who said the
Constitution doesn't really matter and
who would literally say you know who
cares about the 4th amendment the Fifth
Amendment it's also 4th the first
amendment it doesn't really matter this
thing's from hundreds of years ago it's
no longer relevant and look we've got a
job to do there's bad guys out there and
we're going to decide who they are and
what we're going to do about the problem
with that that I would argue is how
designations of national security are
made in the first place there's a
real-life case here that I think's
relevant to a lot of people where the
FBI had a lead on the individual they
were religious leaders sort of community
leader that the government state
believed was in contact with or under
the sway of sort of agents of foreign
power and this is common with all people
who are involved in any kind of radical
politics if you challenge the
prerogatives of state they presume it's
at the direction of another state
because that's simply how the thinking
works the Attorney General was briefed
on the case they said yeah let's wiretap
this guy even though he's a US citizen
son of a popular cleric fairly well
known and they put him on a watch list
said in the event of a national
emergency martial law you know theme and
so on and so forth
we're going to detain this person
because they're dangerous they're a
destabilized they are a radicalized
modern vernacular and the FBI eventually
made a determination that of all of the
similar radicals in the United States
this individual was the most dangerous
from the standpoint of national security
does anybody in the room know this case
do you recognize them
No and the determination was made two
days after he gave the I have a dream
speech that is what a threat to national
security
looks like there's a very real
difference between the public interest
and the national interest when we hear
national interest when you hear national
security
think state interest think state
security and you'll be on the right
track in the case of Ross Ulbricht who
was prosecuted for founding the Silk
Road website and is now effectively he's
appealing it but a life sentence do you
assume or should we assume that the NSA
was involved in corroborating or
gathering evidence which they might have
denied in the actual trial yes yep okay
that's that was easy enough to question
just just to elaborate on that I I
apologize because I don't mean to be pad
their due but the NSA in the United
States is a member of a larger group
called the five eyes Network right this
is the United States the UK Canada New
Zealand and Australia in these five
countries they sort of mix everything
together in a common pot and they share
and share alike they're not allowed to
ask a partner to violate their laws but
partners can share information that
would have been in violation of their
laws if they didn't ask for it now not
to say that particular strategy applied
in this context but the difference
between the National Security Agency's
authorities and particularly the British
equivalent of the NSA called the GCHQ
their authorities is the UK is allowed
to use NSA systems right that we built
and work in the United States and
everything else against are under the
Mandate of what's called a serious
crimes authority that's completely
unrelated national intelligence
prerogatives and this includes drug
trafficking they are literally mandated
for this they use our systems for this
and the fruits of their investigations
they can share freely with us so I would
say yes of course
and it was foolish in the court case I
understand why they did it he didn't
want to own the server at the time he
didn't want to say yes this is mine
therefore the judge wouldn't allow him
to make sort of Fourth Amendment
argument here that investigatory
restrictions have been violated but it
seems unthinkable to me that there was
not intelligence angle internationally
that was involved in that case do you
you know we've talked about government's
we'll do what they can do
well governments at a certain point when
their religion in the minute that Silk
Road was closed
other sites crept up that were dealing
in larger numbers and more traffic will
they give up or will they finally say we
can't really surveil everything nor
should we and so we'll come up with a
different way of dealing with technical
technological innovation and human
commerce look at the prohibition on
alcohol eventually crime groups gained
influence they gained power and they
were difficult to combat as a result
therefore the government re-evaluated
the policy and found that it would be
more in line with their interests non
public interest for their interests if
they end in that prohibition and we see
similar things happening with
prohibition of marijuana today now
that's not to say that I think there
will be necessarily a global
free-for-all
but we are technology is providing new
means to enforce human rights and
traditional compact concepts of human
interaction through technology rather
than through law across borders
regardless of jurisdictions which allow
people to communicate privately
associate privately care about one
another privately without you know for
example in Russia there are prohibitions
on who and how you can love one another
as there were in the United States quite
recently and this this kind of thing is
being challenged in ways that I think
will be difficult to subvert does this
mean that sort of great powers are just
going to you know throw their hands up
give up and walk away
I think that's on
wait however the individual is more
powerful today than they ever have been
in the past and this is why you see
governments that feel threatened by an
individual like Julian Assange who's
trapped in an embassy because despite
the fact that they can control the
physical location of someone the power
of the reliable sort of old bad tools
little regression are increasingly
losing their weight and I you know the
irony is not lost where you're sitting
in an authoritarian you know an
authoritarian regime talking about how
people are freer and more empowered than
ever so you know I mean that is an irony
that I hope that people will cogitate on
for a long time talk about you know when
we talked about the presidential
election what would a candidate have to
do in order for you to say you know what
that is the type of thinking on
surveillance or on individual freedom
and liberty from surveillance that I
could get behind what what would they
have to do i I mean again this this sort
of political Direction gets beyond my
expertise so I don't like to talk too
much about that but you know you might
have an interesting point there about
Russia that I think is actually
important to contextualise there's a lot
of fair criticism reasonable criticism
that's like hey this guy's in Russia
it's important to understand that I
never intended to end up in Russia
originally I was hoping to get to
Iceland after that Latin America when
Iceland fell through but the State
Department canceled my passport trapping
Russia when I was initially off as soon
as they heard I was in the air and
despite the fact that I've asked several
times they've refused to reinstate it
which is quite interesting the United
States of course criticizes me for being
in Russia at the same time they won't
let me leave but be that as it be that
as it may there's there's a deeper point
here a philosophical point here about
hypocrisy is it hypocritical not to be
somewhere else and not be concerned or
as concerned with that locale
as you are with your home and I would
argue that it's not IO my first DVD my
first allegiance my first loyalty to
fixing my country before I try to solve
the problems of the rest of the world
right we've got to get our house in
order first that's not to say that I
haven't criticized the policies of the
russian government which i think in many
cases are are clearly indefensible
particularly when it comes to how they
reach into the internet how they reach
into private lives private homes in ways
that are not okay about sure they're not
okay in the united states and they're
not okay anywhere and this is something
that i expect to continue but the thing
that i hope for the most the thing that
i care about the most is let's set the
standard in the united states that it
has embodied traditionally that is we
are the example for the rest of the
world to emulate we don't want people to
hold us up as an example as in today and
recently this week in this Apple versus
FBI case where apple by the way just
yesterday had a call with the press
where they said no country in the world
has asked us to provide the authorities
that the FBI is doing today
we don't want Russia or China or North
Korea or Iran or France or Germany or
Brazil or any other country in the world
to hold us up as an example for why you
should be narrowing the boundaries of
liberty around the world rather than
expanding
I think sadly so that's another way of
saying you definitely won't be voting in
this election I think how should
children you know would what are the
texts that they should read or what are
the what are the practices that are good
that would give them an independent
critical you know ability to kind of
move into a world which is both
nationalistic in a good sense you're an
American and you seem to be so proud of
being an American and there's something
there worth preserving but but they're
you know so we can be nationalists but
not status where do we go on the
internet where should we be asking our
children to spend some time I think it's
less important to go to specific texts
is to demonstrate how specific texts are
written if I were a parent trying to
help my child understand the Internet
the key exercise that I would do is I
would go look at cases that are super
partisan today right extraordinarily
charged and I would get two radically
different rewritings of the same story
and I'd make them read them and I do
this on a number of different things to
show because this is something that a
lot of older people fall prey to who
aren't so familiar with the unanimity
you know just get their news from their
single landing page portal or whatever
and also young people who get super
filter bubbles because they sort of opt
into communities that create sort of a
groupthink where it's always people who
are agreeing with what they say which
was not available in the same way 20
years ago on the internet and ten years
ago on the internet uh really where it
there there weren't walls that were
quite so high separating communities and
the idea here is to show that the truth
lies spread across the abundance of
sources the beauty of the Internet is
that you no longer have to rely on a
single source you no longer are
vulnerable to the broadcast that is this
is sort of the voice of
this is the list of facts but it's
important to understand the void that
the sources that you prefer can still be
wrong even if they've got the right
principles the right ideas the right
values getting the facts right matters
more than anything else so this I mean
you're talking about the Internet really
as the fulfillment of the Enlightenment
project of kind of competing versions of
truth and a marketplace of ideas and an
understanding about the construction of
knowledge and truth rather than its
self-evident presentation with that
argument following you can just nod so
okay well let me for a final final
question what what would be the
conditions under which you you would
voluntarily return to the United States
right so this is interesting it's
actually evolved quite a bit originally
I volunteered myself for prison but I
said that I wouldn't be I wouldn't allow
myself to be held up as a deterrent to
other people who are trying to do the
right thing and that was fundamentally
contrary to what the government we
wanted to do of course they wanted to
sort of nail a scalp on the wall as a
warning to the others and even though I
was quite flexible here it was Daniel
Ellsberg who leaked the Pentagon Papers
the secret classified history of the war
in Vietnam in 1971 that show the
government had not only lied US needs
more but they kept lying to keep us and
it despite the fact that they knew there
was no way to win and he told me that
this was a mistake and eventually he
convinced me of this in the sense of to
what do we owe our first loyalty to law
or to justice and to submit ourselves to
sort of a government that is
intentionally trying to deter the
political beliefs and political acts of
other people merely on the basis of law
as though that were a substitute for
morality or superior to morality it's a
very dangerous precedent to set now I'm
still this is I think most people
might be surprised by this look but
fairly more trusting in the value of
governing institutions than Daniel
Ellsberg who ever since his initial work
has just he's been an extraordinary
crusader and a true radical in the best
way for more than a generation now but
when it comes to what's the current
context what's the current state of play
that we've we've been at I've told the
government that I would return if they
guarantee a fair trial where I can make
a public interest defense of why this
was done and allow the jury to decide if
it was right or wrong in the context of
both legality and morality and the
United States government responded with
a letter from the Attorney General
saying they promised they would not
torture me I'm not kidding I have that I
have that letter so it's it's to look at
progress but we'll see where it goes
thank you for your time and for your
comments
I presume in New Hampshire
[Applause]